hey guys Pete here got some news today
or last night I guess from george RR
martin about the spin-offs or as he
points out actually they're prequels
there's slight spoilers here if you
don't want to know what isn't going to
be involved in this process because he
does eliminate two of the candidates but
other than that it's pretty much going
to be common knowledge at some point
when HBO's goes ahead and announces
what's going on so this should be pretty
much spoiler free so martin posted to
his blog yesterday evening on may 14th a
post called about those spin-offs where
he corroborated everything that HBO put
out but then also mentioned that there
are some different things going on that
has it come to light yet he says that it
is more or less true everything that
you've heard but the television being
the fast-moving business that it is
there's already been some further
developments as mentioned he said for
what it's worth he doesn't expect she
liked the term spinoff because it
doesn't really apply to these new
projects but we're really talking about
here he says our new story set in the
secondary universe to bar junior or
Tolkien Stern the secondary universe of
Westeros in the world beyond the world
he created for a Song of Ice and Fire
he goes on to mention that none of these
new shows will be spinning off from Game
of Thrones in the traditional sense in
other words there won't be characters
who go on and have their own show or
continue on to another one
so he jokes that they're you know from
people who were hoping for the further
adventures of hot pie are doomed to
disappointment every one of the concepts
under discussion is a prequel rather
than a sequel and that some of them may
not even be set on Westeros rather than
calling them a spin-off or prequel
however he prefers the term successor
show and that's what he's been calling
he says that he has been involved and
has been for months he had his first
meeting with HBO about the possibility
of a successor show back in August when
he pitched them two possible series
what's interesting about this is that
one of them is among the concepts being
developed and another one that he wanted
to do is not and the most that followed
that meeting other writers were brought
in and they pitched other ideas
ultimately HBO decided to go ahead with
four separate developments
be written by Max Borenstein Jane
Goldman Brian Hagen and Carly Rae Martin
clarifies that it was mentioned that he
was working with two of the writers but
that's not quite right he's actually
been working with all four of them every
one of the four has visited him in his
home at Santa Fe some more than once and
they spent days together discussing
their ideas the history of Westeros and
the world beyond in sundry details found
only in the world of Ice and Fire and
the lands of Ice and Fire he says
they're all amazing talents and he's
excited to be working with them in
between visits he's also been in touch
with them by phone text and email and he
expects there will be a lot more back
and forth as they move forward the big
thing the first big thing that he
dropped was is that there's more they
had four scripts and development when he
arrived in LA last week but by the time
that he left they had five they had
added a fifth writer to the original
four he won't give them name he says HBO
announced the first four and will no
doubt announced the fifth as well once
that deal is closed Martin says that he
is a really great addition so we know
it's a man he says he's a great guy and
a fine writer and aside from me and
maybe Ellie oh and Linda from Westeros
org he says he doesn't know of anyone
that knows and loves Westeros as well as
this guy does that is pretty interesting
so some of the reports of the
development seem to suggest that HBO
might be adding four successor shows to
the scheduled replace Game of Thrones
but sites decades of experience in
television and film have taught him that
nothing is ever really certain he says
he does think it's very unlikely they'll
be getting four or five series at least
not immediately but what they do have is
an order for four now five pilot scripts
how many pilots will be filmed and how
many series might come of that remain to
be seen if we do get five series on the
air he says I might have to change my
name to Dick direwolf which I don't even
know what that means but you know it's
direwolf he says that the one thing that
the one goal that everyone involved here
shares is that these shows should be
just as good as Game of Thrones itself
which is no easy task David Benioff and
Dan Weiss are a tough tough act to
follow as all those Emmys demonstrate I
can't tell you what the shows will be
about Martin
and then he clarifies saying he could
but he won't but he will tell us a
couple things that they won't be and
this he says will disappoint some of us
and that he thinks it's better to do
that now than later so there have been a
number of articles videos everything
else about what we speculate these
prequels or successor shows would be and
two things that always come up are The
Adventures of Duncan egg and Robert's
rebellion george RR martin says directly
that they are not doing Duncan aid
eventually he says sure I'd love that
and so with many of the fans but he's
only written and published three
novellas to date and there are at least
seven or eight or ten more that he wants
to write he says we all know how slow he
is and how fast the television show can
move and his main concern here is that
he doesn't want what happened with Game
of Thrones itself to happen with Duncan
egg in other words he doesn't want the
show to get ahead of the books so when
the day comes that he's finished telling
all the tales of Duncan egg then he can
do a TV show about them but that's still
a long ways off he goes on to say that
they are not doing Robert's rebellion
either he says that he knows thousands
of us want that he knows there's a
petition but by the time he finishes
writing the Song of Ice and Fire series
everything we need to know about
Robert's rebellion will be out in the
open so his thinking here is is that
it's basically telling a twice told tale
you know there would be no surprises or
revelations left in such a show they'd
just be acting out conflicts whose
resolutions we as readers already knew
and he doesn't want to do that not now
so we can be sure that there is no
Dunkin egg and no Robert's rebellion he
mentions at the end that he's still
working on one's a winner and he'll
continue until it's done which is good
considering there's that and another
boat to come but then he also mentioned
some of the other things that he does
the five successor shows we're talking
about now five and fire and blood which
is the Georgia are Marillion remember
there's four new wild-card books coming
out and then some other things he can't
tell us about yet and he finishes the
post by saying it's a good thing he
loves his work so it's everything that
he told us in his post and those are
pretty big revelations as far as
concern I mean mostly everybody who come
in on my prequels video five months ago
said they thought Robert's rebellion and
Duncan Hague were good choices and most
of the articles I've read since then and
the time after this has been announced
that those in the know kind of thought
these were Xuan's at least to be
developed as pilots but we found out
that they are not so what does that mean
I mean they're making five different
successor shows the writing and possibly
developing five different pilots but two
of the most likely adaptations we
thought we saw coming here out of the
running it sort of brings up more
questions than it answers when you think
about it
yeah like we don't know more than we did
a week ago that's for sure
I mean what makes the most sense here I
think that the Targaryen and the Starks
are the most popular and recognizable
families in the running obviously
there's a long long history in both
families the Targaryens are kind of
written about more at least in the world
of Ice and Fire
because they were the kings and there's
a listing of all that we also know that
he's writing a story that's a historical
story not not like the ones that he
makes like the novellas or the main
series more like the dance of dragons
but he is doing that about two of the
early Targaryen Kings so he's I'm
working on that maybe that figures into
this that's going to be titled the sons
of the Dragon and it deals with the
second and third Targaryen Kings II nice
the first and make or the first he's
also known as maegor the cruel they
followed behind Aegon the conquerer and
this is a story that he's read parts of
it cons before it conventions and so
it's been around and he could be he
could have had that completed for the
most part for some time so it's possible
there's an adaptation in the works but
if they do that would that follow after
Aegon's conquest or I mean are they
setting up to do a Targaryen run either
way sons of the Dragons supposed to be
out in October 2017 and it's going to be
part of an anthology called
book of swords which is an anthology
edited by Gardner Dozois or something
like that as mentioned it'll be
historical so it'll be you know written
from the
view of archmaester kaldane from Old
Town I think a lot of people think the
dance of the Dragons is going to be
something that is going to be developed
it seems really expensive and crazy to
me but seems all the more likely now
since we know that Robert's rebellion is
not in the works
I think Aegon's conquest makes sense
still I don't really see the rogue
Prince being up there and things that
people would make so you know it's
really kind of up in the air again maybe
I you know maybe later this week if
anybody watches this video my last one
about the spin also is my least watch
Game of Thrones video of all time so
maybe it's not worth it to make these
videos right now I can actually
concentrate on some of the other shows
I've been watching but I mean I'm still
a fanatic so I would like to continue to
delve into the subject though we'll see
maybe all of what they're working on is
Targaryen related many people have
brought up the Blackfyre rebellion as a
great idea for a spin-off I guess
but if Duncan egg is out of the equation
that kind of takes away some of those so
does that make it more likely that the
first Blackfyre rebellion is one of
these projects I think that's a
possibility that's been written about
enough and people obviously like that
period of history so yeah maybe all of
these things are Targaryen related and
you know just by what we talked about
here we can see where it's going let me
know what you guys think are you really
disappointed about Robert's rebellion
and Duncan egg being off the table do
you think this makes some of the other
choices more likely and with all this
stuff on his plate do you ever see a
time when he finishes any of this stuff
I mean one of the takeaways here is that
he's not actually scripting anything
whenever that you know the original
reports said he was working with two of
the writers he kind of cleared up that
he's not like working with them as in
developing scripts but he's just you
know he's just basically consulting with
all of them that's good as far as how
the future of the rest of the series
Song of Ice and Fire series is concerned
but I mean do you think that this is
ever going to get done I mean there's
other actual George RR Martin's stuff
going on I think sci-fi is announced
that they're going to develop night
fliers which is one of his sci-fi books
we have that coming we know wild cards
is coming with
you know it really hit stories but sort
of his universe I guess and he did write
some of the stories so you know there's
a lot of different things that are
coming out and it's really hard to see
how he finishes everything I mean I'm
totally holding out for it but it's just
he's a super busy guy at this point so
let me know what you think in the
comments please subscribe to my channel
and if you do leave a comment you will
be entered into my book giveaway which
is going on I'll let you know more
details about that in the next video for
now thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon